one more day and can you believe it
i'm leading the match
for the first time i'm leading the match
i'm one up
and i need two more points to clinch it
and we're gonna get ourselves another
grin folks
let me see what he's got let me see what
he's got here
sure he has some tricky like ah this is
this is why you go
wish b3 first i think yeah this is it
you go bishop b3 first
so that you can develop the knight to f3
once they go knight c6
what i did is actually slightly
slightly inaccurate
what can you do
yeah this is maybe more than slightly
inaccurate
okay so i don't particularly want
f3 rook to d8 do door
okay so i'll go convince you too
this is also stupid 1985
bishop d3 c5
and i have to take on c5 i think
okay i believe rooft
may it be a little helpful to me
question mark
probably not because after rd195 they're
still
the same the same [ __ ]
okay i just i'm just misplacing my
pieces
okay d5 is not something you want to do
positionally speaking but
i didn't see what to do and at least now
that he's
he moved his rook from um
from d8 then f5 is a little harder to
attain
maybe now i can do this and play for f4
[Music]
but
i would be lying if i said i loved it
i actually would be lying if i even said
i liked it
okay here four i'm not so sure about now
i got measure d4
it feels like i'm sort of getting some
activity
like if he goes c6 i don't react i just
go bishop d4
after this one i don't commission b4
this thing this that's the one thing i
can say for sure
um so how do i get
activity okay let's go c4 first
he reroutes the night
probably that doesn't have activity
guys i'm just getting outplayed
just a bit annoying of course
yes the recommended e5 now
i don't see any reason why not to go
bishop e5
bishop c3 f6
foreign
okay i'll go a4 just present b5
because queen e8 i go bishop c3
and if then bishop a4 queen b2 f6 will
be met by
knight e6 so we cannot actually hold the
blockade
so we'd be pretty happy to see that
this one i'm less happy to see but i'll
try and regroup
knight to c3 and the bishop to f4
or clearly bishop to f4 first
since i don't want to allow knight to
three queen h4
okay queen h4 i'll go
bishop to f4
i have to take back with the knight and
f4 but i don't think that's a disaster
because the rope will be hanging on e1
otherwise
yeah if it takes another four
i don't know i don't think it's too
clear okay now i'll take an e5
i believe okay
we will go tonight either to c3 or to
g1 and then f3 probably to g1 and f3
i feel like i've i've achieved something
here
okay we'll go 92
claim that the knight is slightly better
there
okay queen b2 probably
try and annoy him a bit
takes rp8 no
h3 knight f3 has to go knight f7
bishop c2 detects
and now i think i am slightly better
because he has very very few
very very few useful moves maybe the
knight is even better on d3
because then the f file is open
i possibly want to go bishop d1 and
bishop g4
later on provoke the exchange of
of those bishops
okay knight d3
so he just he's just protecting
everything for the moment
go rook b1 c3
okay like the king is a little bit
better on g1
[Music]
one just reminding him that
i'm calling the shots here
my g5 you can go rookie to me so i'm not
worried about this
the knight will go to f3 after all
just hinting at [ __ ] page five making
him think
that is important always threaten
something
rook f8 now he may be
putting himself in a little bit of a not
unpleasant pin
though may not be that bad
okay we go back hinting at going to g4
at some point
now queen b2
and rook f1 and bishop h5 may be coming
scratch five and it's game over
take it
take d7 i think
then we just push
six no reason not to
take b6 he doesn't even have a check
take another one we check
and we'll give a check
and another one take another pawn
because there's no hurry
only one check no stalemate and
that's it okay
i think that was that was like i
wouldn't say
a decent game but at least like
i recognized that it was not going well
for me so i tried just to keep the game
going
and little by little i gained the
advantage and
then when he went for this h4 g5
stuff that just turned out to
decisively weaken his king so my patient
was
certainly rewarded there